what was your reaction to gma 3 getting
cancelled
expected kiki palmer always keeps it
real
which is exactly what the triple threat
did on sunday's watch what happens live
after show
addressing the shake up at her daytime
talk show strahan sarah and kiki
amid the chronovirus pandemic you know
when the pandemic hit that's what we
were all
that's what became all on our minds was
the pandemic corona understanding kobe
to get you up to speed ssk was bumped
off abc
in march instead they started airing a
daily coronavirus report in its place
kiki told host andy cohen she
understands why it had to happen
i kind of knew that you know if our show
did come back it would
have to be much much much later because
our show is really about an audience you
know when you think about it we that's
what we do we do a little bit of news
but it's entertainment news it's really
fun conversations and light-heartedness
so the time
different time now so some of the
conversation has changed and i think
just it kind of pushed ssk out it's
worth noting that abc has
yet to officially announce the show as
cancelled
a spokesperson for the network told et
in july that they're proud of how
quickly
the ssk and gma teams adapted during
these unprecedented times and adds
conversations continue about how the
show will evolve in the months ahead
i expected it as one chapter closes fans
are ready for another one to open
with rumors swirling that kiki may join
the real
following amanda seals and tamara mowry
housley's departures
no no no no no none of that but um yeah
so straight hamster and kiki is gone
but you know a lot of other good stuff
in the works yeah let's talk about that
other good stuff last month the 26 year
old hustler star addressed speculation
that her support for the black lives
matter movement impacted abc's decision
to cancel ssk
kiki shared this lengthy post on
instagram confirming her views had
nothing to do with it
explaining in part quote if anything my
speaking out showed the corporations i
work with
how important my voice is kiki also
asked fans to simply view the situation
like this
quote seem he has a brand that works
with the corporation disney abc news
and this particular show i was on is no
longer that does not mean the
relationship i have with them dies
that means it evolves it's weird it's
different
but we're finding our way back in may et
spoke with kiki via video chat
and even then she had this to say about
the changes ssk was going through
i have to say it's so weird because i
think so much of our show and what made
our show
it's made our show ssk is is the fact
that we have audiences the fact that
we're having fun and
you know i think uh right now i think
people need so much
fun but at the same time you want to
make sure tony that it makes sense
because everybody also is having such a
hard time
um so it's weird it's different i just
can't wait to we're all back together
[Music]
again